martin and lynn
[Applause]
[Music]
lin fell down hardens made the basket
talk about breaking some ankles and
misses
and capela with a rebound gets it up
ahead to harden
behind his back
gonna be up to hardin great crossover to
the basket over the back
and howard ties the game in 99. what a
pass from
james harden he's the guy you have to
watch cj
stayed right with him harden gets a pick
from capella throws his head back gets
the foul and the bucket
[Applause]
[Music]
hart gets a pick from capella nice pass
and capella does the rest what an assist
by the beard we're going to begin the
second half for the rockets
he does everything back to the villain
and he drops the sledgehammer what a
play
the move the drive and in the anvil
point deficit
[Applause]
[Music]
nice play off the beautiful feed final
seconds of the first
terry to harden harden at the buzzer oh
he knocks it down
tyler ennis has checked in for the first
time as a rocket just acquired
a week or so governor another alley flay
for mike d'antoni's offense but as this
progresses this marriage between these
two teams another
fantastic fade from james harden but you
wonder
what can james harden do for mike
d'antoni
not too many better athletes than
jonathan simmons who went to smiley high
school here in houston played for the u
of h one year
and james with the craze
out tonight for rest harold will get a
chance to play there's an errant pass
hardin in the open court
nice pass pontes harrell whoa
to play with james hart
[Music]
utah has committed to gordon hayward
they paid him the big contract
what a fantastic pass from hart
offensive rebound bledsoe aries a right
place right time
hard oh what a pass behind the back to
mantras
[Applause]
tough to score on these grizzlies in a
long three ball attempt by hard
it's gonna count plus the foul from
30-plus
clippers made a run here in the second
quarter a blocked shot by matress
harrell
harding in the open court flips out
[Applause]
it isn't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and they're right back in this game at
halftime
[Applause]
[Applause]
what i found james harden rebound to a
reason
pass and capela with the finish
what a pass martin working on the rookie
steps back and fires down it counts
[Applause]
by james
[Music]
[Applause]
taco bell skills challenge last night
posting live on social media
archiving with the photos and designing
a custom trophy
for christopher porzingis
pat digs it out up the court in a hurry
james back to capella
rockets offense 94-4
advances with the pass
james goes right past teagan lays it out
wow right to capella
and that's the best alley-oop
combination in the league number 45
between the two of those guys and a good
job by capela to avoid the foul on
hayward
harden great down court pass he saw the
mismatch
for he sees the court 94 feet
battle down low there between lopez and
then gets stopped
carter williams on the three banked it
up and in
it will count in a rare four point
opportunity coming up here
for james harden or jamir nelson will
take it
six seconds left on the run harden all
the way
[Applause]
[Music]
themselves after the bad start oh harden
throws it down
troy williams he's got rockets in his
rear end
look at that beautiful executed place
westbrook is on the bench right now
for the dance that move is illegal in
most every state
except in texas wow
eight point game under a minute to go
[Applause]
got 16 points and eight assists but not
a single rebound
inside dropping it hard
great feed by james harden
[Music]
and he stuffs it on gasol
goes to his offhand the right hand just
slide that one down
[Applause]
what a play there to get the final shot
[Music]
that's usually this man doing it to the
basket for hardin for two
does it every time james harden whether
it's a three
or a two if they so chew
pulls harden trigger got it
james harden is houston stroller
[Music]
oh my goodness again each one
is better than the one previously he
drives
kicks the harden with derozan there
oh no no no no no no
oh james harden barton on vaughn leg
he has scored the last seven make it the
last nine for the rockets
just fake van lay out of his jock strap
the athlete yeah that's right
she made that shot and made it look easy
boy is she a good swimmer yes indeed
with it up and under and he'll go to the
free-throw line to add one to it
harden curry switches off four to shoot
harden shake and bake steps back
three-pointer
bang
it was beauty gonna throw the long lob
how about that a 45-foot pass
from james harden to clint capela so
mike d'antoni needs those points between
the legs
[Applause]
action right off the bat shot clock at
seven
seconds hosonia and hardin
hart steps back fires
[Music]
james harden is the new scoring
one game champion for the houston
rockets and kelvin murphy on his feet
jack clock at six now for the rockets
hard and fakes gets past crowder gets
inside
throws it over his shoulder and puts it
in count it and the foul
as harden with a chance for the
traditional three-point play
the nets have taken more threes than the
rockets
here tonight
martin euro the finish
james martin getting to the cup
[Applause]
rockets have numbers at least for now
behind the back and then
the best sequence of the night for
houston
and jimmy butler is still
down holding his right knee as hard he
gets it to go
do you think he was certain to work i
thought it was going to be
oh made it hard oh he stared at wesley
johnson
and then he hit the three wow he put him
on the deck
and then he hesitated
final seconds of the half here is horn
it does james harden
beats the buzzer
[Applause]
harden garnered by the rookie little
shake and bake pass inside the nene
gathers lays it up and in beautiful
assist from james harden his third here
in the first quarter
might come in number two but they're not
winning the mvp this year
davis went out of bounds on that shot
here comes hardin behind the back
and since anthony davis was out of
bounds on that crazy shot clint capela
had a wide open dunk
what a team like this get into a game
early
oh what a great move by the beard
can't guard him 101 of course
18 seconds left to play rockets need a
three the tie
james steps back
james harden gets his first
three-pointer tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
by as many as 11. now leading
oh that was a big hammer back down
dribble get a separation because
anderson has some length he's got the
last six for minnesota
as harden takes it strong the goal
gibson is on heart
[Applause]
hammers at home
harvey's got the rebound to play
[Applause]
[Applause]
unloads undrafted in 2015
played overseas for a couple of years
it's been an impressive rookie this year
as harden hits the bomb
[Music]
[Applause]
just like that he baits him by making it
through
all right thank you david here's harden
with the drive
a facial by james harden going
right at draymond green and a lot of
chatter out there
miller gave it all this christian led
low work on the sideline
and hardened
i would expect that he would sit here in
the fourth quarter down to four seconds
down to three
behind the back razzle dazzle there it
is
james harden with his ninth three of the
game
just think about it the guy was at home
without a job
pardon blows past james and throws it
[Applause]
down
82 combined between harden and gordon
got fouled and won
that's a half a hundy for head back
chris who was sitting
right here for that seventh game of the
western conference final in astonishment
as here's horton got the step and stop
oh what a move and he went right at
jeffree mcgee a 10-2 run here
summit on that play both guys were
determined to get a play for their team
harvey
[Applause]
even robinson was a great shot blocker
patrick ewing
[Applause]
[Music]
for james harden and that may be the
game-winner
[Applause]
[Music]
arden backs up and tries it again yes
he does it again
[Applause]
trying to get three down to three down
to two it's a three
good good he got it
james hardened a flame thrower
incredible shot it's murray and harden
fives licking his chops
he fell down
[Music]
with
[Music]
with a step back three got another one
shaking his head looking at milwaukee's
bench saying you can't guard me now
step back oh
it's a three plus one
[Applause]
from the parking lot he was out there in
the parking lot
all by himself he's smart
over there on the opposite side of the
floor
good defense by kyrie wow
butter by james harden
damien lee comes in for the first time
curry and green
return harden step back gets down and
one
chance for a four-point play as hard
knocks down his first three-pointer of
the game
in our league yeah because he's a good
penetrator good hustler yes he is
number one draft choice that's going to
be two-and-one jackson
saw him coming couldn't do anything
about it
oh my somebody give kent base more a map
so he can locate james harden
seven seconds on the shot clock
over are you kidding me he just shot
that from sugarland
to get past that rebound goes to capela
back to hardin oh i think he was up so
high
he got a bloody nose i love that
celebration
i love that one let me tell you
something he's getting an opportunity
between the legs to capella showtime
[Applause]
hardin throws it up and he goes in
everything this season is going in for
james harden they won 65 games last
season so
this season was just about the
postseason and then they had
harden at the buzzer shot clock again
down to five hard
step back three
hardened tonight three of seven
thompson's defense there
step back
[Applause]
he's done it again
rockets will have the lead at the break
the question
will be by how much
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
eight straight for houston fouls to give
both in the penalty
under two to play harden step back puts
up the three got hit
shots good and one james harden
double team and a chance for a four
point play
he just looked at the crowd and said
wow like he is in awe of himself at this
point don't
reach because he's gonna preach and then
you're forced to close out
and
[Applause]
they know what they want
hopefully it's a mate three
[Music]
[Applause]
and it is to beat the buzzer in the
third quarter
picked up by pj tucker off the harden
and there's smith right there
j.r is on him harden goes by him and
counted to go
pretty play by james harden
houston got its hands on it
dort for three blocked by hardin dart
got it back
tried to throw it off harden and missed
him
[Music]
covington defending harvey covington
trying not to give up the three hard and
step back three
[Applause]
two in a row for james harden